estas imágenes difundidas por Estados
Unidos muestran como su dron cae en el
mar Negro tras Aparentemente chocar con
una aeronave rusa en esta última
escalada de tensiones entre Estados
Unidos y Rusia a pesar de las imágenes
mientras que Washington sostiene que el
avión no tripulado fue alcanzado por un
caza ruso
Moscú sigue negando que se produjera
contacto alguno algo por lo que el
miércoles los ministros de defensa de
ambos países iniciaron conversaciones
telefónicas
No hablaré En nombre del ministro shoygu
ni entrar en los detalles de nuestra
discusión me limitaré a reiterar que
Estados Unidos volará y operará allí
donde lo permita el derecho
internacional ahora bien nos tomamos muy
en serio cualquier posibilidad de
escalada y por eso creo que es
importante mantener abiertas las líneas
de comunicación
es el primer incidente directo entre
Rusia y Estados Unidos desde que comenzó
la guerra en Ucrania según Washington es
una prueba de comportamiento agresivo y
arriesgado del kremlin en aguas
internacionales y según Moscú el dron
demuestra la implicación de Estados
Unidos en la guerra y advierte que
podría provocar a más tensiones
se constató que los drones estratégicos
letales estadounidenses en la costa de
crimea tuvieron una actitud provocativa
y crearon condiciones para una escalada
de la situación en la zona del mar Negro
tras este incidente ambas naciones
deciden querer evitar una escalada pero
con las relaciones en un punto crítico
podrían producirse consecuencias
diplomáticas